he tratado con gente homofóbica como
cualquier otra persona hay muchas cosas
que puedo manejar menos que alguien me
lastimé
[Música]
el espectro parejas casadas
nos presionaron para casarnos
321 ya
somos mormones y había mucha presión en
nuestra iglesia para casarnos
especialmente en la escuela de la
iglesia a la que asistimos nos casamos a
los 5 meses porque queríamos y nos
amábamos pero siento que hay mucha
presión social es por eso que no estoy
de acuerdo no estoy de acuerdo porque no
siento que seamos y siento que estábamos
un poco presionados para casarnos luego
que nos conocimos y les dijimos a
nuestras familias dijeron oye tal vez
deberían reducir la velocidad así que
nos presionaron para que no nos
casáramos si yo diría que cero depresión
cuando vi por primera vez a esta mujer
dije tengo que conocerme cariño
sinceramente ambos veníamos de hogares
rotos ambos veníamos de familias
divorciadas y teníamos el gran deseo de
tener un matrimonio sólido así que nunca
he confiado tanto en alguien como en ver
gay no hubo presión la presión era sobre
mí espero que ya sienta lo mismo que yo
siento por ella
y nosotros salimos por menos de un año
pero cuando lo sabes lo sabes verdad
tengo algunas preguntas calientes
enviadas por nuestra audiencia
así que leer el mensaje y ustedes
estarán de acuerdo o en desacuerdo con
el mensaje en el matrimonio la mujer
trabaja más
siento que ninguno debería trabajar más
que el otro en un matrimonio ya que para
que un matrimonio funcione debe existir
igualdad quizás sólo sea una opinión
idealista no lo sé
declaración general la mayoría de las
mujeres que conozco incluidas las que me
criaron tenían un trabajo también se
ocupaban de los niños la mayor parte del
tiempo la mayoría de las tareas del
hogar también recaían en la mujer y la
mayoría de las veces la mujer acepta dos
trabajos literalmente
he pensado en el divorcio
aprendimos esto en una clase en donde
hay un rinoceronte y un erizo en cada
relación matrimonial
entonces charlie es el rinoceronte
tenemos que abordarlo ahora tenemos que
hablar para mí yo soy el erizo necesito
retirarme así que pienso que en esos
momentos no sé y creo que me siento así
solo es cuando estás en el calor del
momento me pueden entender si
definitivamente sé que nuestro estilo de
comunicación es totalmente diferente no
nos comunicamos bien al principio sé que
kim si proviene de una familia
divorciada y he visto que su familia
pelea y grita mucho yo vengo de una
familia donde si mis padres tenían un
desacuerdo peleaban fuera de nuestra
vista y a puerta cerrada así que tener
desacuerdos tener conversaciones
incómodas y difíciles para mí no fue
nada fácil así que el divorcio suena más
fácil que seguir adelante lo cual
afortunadamente hicimos y lo estamos
haciendo muy bien ahora estamos felices
pero sin duda hubo un momento en el que
si parecía más fácil dejarlo todo y
seguir adelante en lugar de
reconciliarse me satisface la frecuencia
con que tenemos relaciones
[Música]
hay un erizo un rinoceronte y luego hay
un conejo siento que soy la coneja en
este matrimonio mis
expectativas y mi deseo
sexual son mi límite es muy alto pero
siempre ha sido así así que sinceramente
estamos sobre la mesa a veces el trabajo
y la vida se interponen en el camino las
responsabilidades pero pienso si
buscamos un término medio los dos
estamos aquí si nos hubiéramos separado
entonces sería evidencia de que hemos
hablado al respecto
pero esto no es una sorpresa para mí no
creo que les sorprenda que ambos estemos
aquí porque es algo de lo que hemos
hablado es algo en lo que estamos
trabajando y es que cuando te casas que
hacen una rutina te pones a trabajar y
sales y al final del día estás agotado
los dos somos personas ambiciosas y a
veces eso es en detrimento del hogar en
ambos extremos no solo eres tú así que
yo quiero hijos
321 ya
y si pudiéramos tendríamos un bebé ayer
pero como somos del mismo sexo tener un
bebé significa un gran costo entonces
compramos una casa el año pasado y fue
algo grande para nosotras lo de los
hijos está sobre la mesa pero cada niño
cuesta unos 40 mil dólares si queremos
dos serían unos ochenta mil dólares como
una casa como mujeres nuestro reloj está
en marcha envejecemos y tenemos menos
tiempo para hacerlo realidad así que
para nosotras es diferente tenemos
problemas de infertilidad he tenido tres
abortos tuve uno recientemente es un
tema sensible porque el aborto ocurrió
la semana pasada y fue muy duro se lo
habíamos dicho a nuestras familias y
estábamos muy emocionados para
anunciarlo a todos y
discúlpenme
se me parte el corazón porque sé que nos
unimos más pero es lo más difícil que
hemos tenido que pasar juntos porque sé
que tyler será un excelente padre me
siento mal porque le he dicho que está
bien si quieres casarte con otra persona
y tener hijos porque sé que no puedo
darte luz
si ha sido muy difícil lidiar todo esto
porque no es un tema que se puede hablar
mucha gente se siente muy incómoda cada
vez que surge esa conversación mis
padres han tratado de ayudarnos pero
realmente no saben cómo a veces siento
que no quiero seguir me digo no no vale
la pena la angustia y la lucha económica
no vale la pena pero al final del día sé
que aquí es donde quiero estar
no me agrada la familia de mi pareja
321 ya
muy en desacuerdo parcialmente en
desacuerdo de acuerdo es un desafío
de la verdad lo sé
varios varios miembros de tu familia que
los adoro
está bien bien hubo un momento en el que
quería amar a tu madre pero luego hubo
un momento que no pude tengo un
caparazón sabían lo que me estaba
metiendo he tratado con personas
homofóbicas como cualquier otra persona
y puedo manejar muchas cosas lo que no
puedo soportar es verte sufrir
y esa es la parte más difícil porque
eres increíble y ella se lo está
perdiendo
entiendo perfectamente por qué estás
parada ahí ojalá pudieras estar aquí
conmigo pero me críe en una familia
homofóbica y lamentablemente no puedes
elegir donde naces así que entiendo tu
frustración ya que he sufrido esa
frustración y la he llevado
durante toda mi vida y me sorprende que
estés ahí no yo no lo creo yo creo que
esto es un lado positivo no cuando me
casé contigo gané una familia y aunque
puedo no estar de acuerdo con ciertos
puntos de vista de tu familia en general
tu familia ha sido cariñosa desde el
momento en que entré en tu vida y le
agradezco por eso porque siento que
presione mucho a mis amigos porque son
mi familia pero cuando te conocí siento
que tu familia llenó ese vacío que yo
tenía
hermoso del matrimonio es que pueden
sentar un nuevo precedente tienes la
oportunidad de establecer un nuevo
estándar para tu familia y eso es lo que
tiene de hermoso no tienes que asumir lo
que tu familia trajo ni lo que tu
familia te dio pueden hacer algo nuevo
hay cosas que mi pareja no sabe de mí
321 ya
yo he tenido muchas dificultades en mi
vida que lleva tiempo descubrir y hablar
me siento como si tuviera un trauma y tú
también necesitas terapia tú me
mostraste tu trauma antes de unirnos
nos conocimos en una aplicación de citas
y sus primeros mensajes antes de tener
una cita fueron por cierto pasé por esto
esto esto esto y esto en los últimos
doce meses crea más o menos yo te
traumatice en la primera cita entonces
dije bien si ella sigue aquí el final de
la cita entonces tengo que casarme con
ella y aquí está el aro y si hay algo
que no sé son las cosas nuevas que
exploramos juntas no nos enfocamos en el
pasado como lo que comiste en tu tercer
cumpleaños seguramente no lo sé pero
exploremos todo lo nuevo porque si eres
mi futuro
estoy con mi alma gemela
321 ya
esa es una cuestión interesante
yo no
estoy de acuerdo con el término alma
gemela
por estar aquí no estoy diciendo que no
eres la persona con la que se supone que
debo estar sólo estoy diciendo que tenía
tantas oportunidades de hacer cosas
diferentes y tomar diferentes caminos en
mi vida y yo elegí este y todos los días
seguiré eligiendo este si no sabía que
eso era lo que significaba para ti
primera vez que te escucho explicarlo de
esa manera para mí el alma gemela es
alguien que sabes que quieres en tu vida
y cuando tú y yo nos contamos
simplemente no había miedo no había
novia nada más no tuve ninguna duda
volviendo al principio dijimos que
cuando lo sabes lo sabes y siento que no
nos conocimos por accidente fue un
evento
divino porque estado para que nos
cruzáramos ya que yo crecí en los
ángeles y charly en detroit
así que fue por alguna razón un buen
matrimonio no ocurre por casualidad
requiere trabajo tiempo de calidad pero
no me gustaría vivir con nadie más
jay es lesbiana has amado a las mujeres
desde el principio yo me identifico como
bisexual antes de conocerla nunca quise
casarme cuando estaba con mujeres quería
hombres cuando estaba con hombres quería
mujeres sentía que me faltaba algo
entonces te conocí y todo cambió en mi
alma en mi cuerpo y en mis elecciones
solía no creer en el alma gemela porque
sentía que de los miles de millones de
personas en este mundo solo te unes a
una y el universo se alinea es mucho
trabajo para el universo pero cuando
funciona no hay otra explicación para
que pueda cambiar tanto dentro de mí al
conocer a una persona esto quedó
perfecto
[Risas]
muy bien